welcome to Hannity all right we start
with the major Fox News Alert breaking
news multiple fronts just moments ago
the New York Times has in fact reported
and confirmed that bars Department of
Justice have now shifted the probe into
the origins of the Russia collusion
witch-hunt it is now officially a
criminal investigation this is a major
huge development finally we might get to
the truth as we have been demanding for
quite a while let me tell you what this
means that means the US attorney John
Durham who has subpoena power he has the
ability to will panel a grand jury and
file criminal charges in this case this
is a major development literally
breaking in the last few minutes and
this means that the suspect criminal
activity clearly the deep state they are
in a state of panic tonight and it's
getting obvious they're desperately
trying to get ahead of this story and
tonight the deep state their messengers
at the Times have every reason to be
afraid every reason to panic because bar
the Attorney General is now apparently
getting closer to the truth
warranting this big development and
that's not all also breaking only
moments ago we learned the inspector
general's report on FISA abuse will soon
finally be released to we the people of
public with very few redactions we have
more on these huge developments coming
up all throughout the hour also what I'm
about to tell you is not a joke yes
Hillary Clinton is now apparently
considering yet another run for the
White House that's right you heard me
correctly one longtime Clinton adviser
quoted as saying that a third
presidential bid is not out of the
question and that his former boss would
quote think long and hard about entering
the race I think the Trump campaign
would probably be thrilled for that
rematch I wonder if she's gonna pay for
another Russian dossier I wonder if
she'll also have another secret server
Clint was already humiliated once losing
it to the presidency in an electoral
landslide since then she's come up with
a whole lot of excuses let's see Russian
BOTS internet troll factories Facebook
ads media coverage Fox News her emails
James Comey even blaming the flashing
videos on the dark web and of course she
blamed Russia collusion I never
and the fact that it was her campaign
that actually paid for the dirty Russian
dossier and by the way the DNC we now
know was colluding with Ukraine
look at this Politico January 11 2017
for some reason Hillary Clinton has yet
to consider that voters just don't like
her she sees Russians Russians
everywhere apparently by the way
speaking of which Democratic hopeful
Tulsi Gabbard will join us today on this
program and as Hillary Clinton
baselessly accused her of being groomed
to be a Russian operative to help Russia
she served her country that's a
disgraceful comment I mean while Tulsi
just abandoned Hillary Clinton quote
stepped down from her throne my
interview with congresswoman Gabbard in
this hour plus the great one Mark Levin
is on fire what he will do tonight you
will not see or hear anywhere else on
any news channel in full detail how this
is an illegitimate secret soviet-style
a Peach Pit coup attempt that is going
on in the house total lawlessness all
precedent pushed aside no due process it
should be in the front to every American
whether you're liberal conservative
Republican or Democrat this is about law
and justice and constitutionality by the
way it's something you'd expect to see
in the former Soviet Union as I
mentioned or maybe Venezuela or Cuba or
any other Banana Republic not here in
the United States of America now make no
mistake if Democrats if they can
formally persecute a president in secret
the way they're doing this behind closed
doors nobody is safe and as we reported
last night Senator Lindsey Graham well
he in fact followed through today with
his resolution condemning the corrupt
Adam Schiff and of course his secret
coup attempt already 46 Republican
senators have signed on to this measure
that is huge in less than 24 hours and
it slams the House Democrats were
violating quote basic cornerstone rights
detailed in the United States
Constitution take a look at your screen
now these were the rules during Bill
Clinton's impeachment this is what
happened when Newt Gingrich was speaker
the house openly debated and held an
official vote the scope was of the Inc
was defined members could see the
evidence imagine voting members can
actually see evidence as it stands now
virtually no one can see anything the
hearings are in secret the transcripts
are in secret not even members of
Congress are allowed to view the
transcripts unless they serve on the
Intel committee by the way they go over
to see it Republicans on the committee
they can only view the transcript if one
of shifts minders one of his staffers a
present by the way other rights afforded
to Clinton include the ability to have
counsel present the ability to
cross-examine the ability to call
witnesses submit evidence and build a
case well these are not revolutionary
concepts in any way shape matter or form
we're talking about basic rights basic
jurisprudence due process that is
supposed to be afforded to every
American accused of wrongdoing
apparently that doesn't apply to
President Trump
well why because he beat them in 2016